his stories are like nets in which you
you catch for a moment something
ineffable something almost
incommunicable but he has communicated
cs lewis was just a master of language
he knew how to point beyond words
the great thing about lewis was that he
was creative and imaginative as well as
being highly intellectual and analytical
he's so skillful and expressingly
inexpressible
what you'll get in this course is an
insight into how lewis understood
christianity and wrote about it both in
his non-fiction and his fiction he knows
what it is like to have been an atheist
being an unbeliever being a skeptic and
he knows what it's like to have come to
faith lewis had thought his way into all
corners of the christian faith pain
joy love miracles prayer heaven hell
and we're going to cover the whole gamut
of experience
that's the great thing about lewis
presentation of the faith he makes it
live he makes it sing he makes it move
he gives it color that i think is one of
the things that people say we love about
louis they feel like they're not just
reading books they're reading life and
life with a capital l
c.s lewis
explained to the world in beautiful
english
in common sense language
why christianity is both good
and plausible
when you come to lewis's writings it's
like you touched a live why you've
suddenly got an electric shock because
here's someone who really believes it
and manages to communicate how much it
means to him
i'm michael ward this is c.s lewis on
christianity let's begin